nabil we're here at fright fest a film
tablet tell me about your role in it
well I play a rather dodgy fella who
along with a friend of his is
responsible for for quite a heinous
attack on one of our protagonists it was
just a big laugh for me it was an
opportunity to have action and in order
to get shot so that was that was me you
know it was just the world crafted
script that's why I really fell about it
and how are the directors was there's
two of them in this film how did they
direct you at the pair i saw he's a
funny one because with to her exes
you're like ok one tells you one thing
and the next one you think I hope he
says the same thing but they were very
they were very synchronized two heads
but one body one heart it was that kind
of a thing no how did it compare to
other jobs that you did you know it's
always funny it's like it was it was it
was good at canyon I was it was a
different thing for me I never normally
that I don't normally do kind of
psychological horror as if you are me
and to be put in that predicament where
a group of people are stuck and can't
move is fantastic you know it brings out
the best and the worst and be me and
that's why I think the film successfully
does why do you think we're seeing what
if you film certain tablets now I've had
attack the block happen we've got the
raid as well and now tower block what is
it about tower blocks there so
frightening blazes nothing by the very
nature that they're a blot that there's
a can only get in one sorta you know
from only at several entrances reminds
me of the old 80's horrors things like
burning inferno and things like that you
know the idea that would be stuck
somewhere you couldn't get out who
you're gonna take you know who do you
saved you save yourself would you save
your loved one well do you just let them
all die it was all that kind of thing so
I think it caught really touches in taps
into that kind of fear from us that's
what's coming up next to you Nabil what
currently I was lucky enough to work on
a on Kathryn Bigelow's new film which
would be very interesting for next year
I'm actually producing a TV drama so
fingers crossed that was something that
will hit your screens at some point but
I'm really just concentrating on just
trying to see what's out there I'm
really interested in meeting new people
and collaborating on new project but you
know we'll see it's an interesting time
to be enacted as for sure tell me a bit
more about that Kathryn Bigelow movie
basically I mean I play a player
character who reveal some information
it's about it's really about the plan of
hunt for Solomon Lancers there's quite
an interesting project I mean she's a
legend for me she directed some of my
favorite films strange days and Point
Break I mean two classics so you know
I've been very lucky to work with new
brilliant directors and some and some
Oscar winners what is it that makes it
so great you think as you say she's very
eclectic in the film she makes this a
shame God if I knew I'd copy it and do
it myself I can't tell you I just think
she has an incredible vision directing
is such an interesting thing to do is
you've got to be so strong world yet
it's so collaborative so where do you
kind of mix that you know you've kind of
got trust you I don't think I'd be a
very good director I'd change it if
you'd say you say oh I think we should
do that different oh yeah Jack instead I
can see the point in everybody else's
opinion and that's probably what makes
me a decent actor I hope
and what kind of directors she would he
think how did she compared to other
people's work to every relax very
relaxed I'm gonna get a shirred I guess
you've want to ask and you know what
you're doing and she was very active
friendly very calm around the actors you
never got the impression that it was a
you know a big kind of Hollywood film
and the same with town I mean Ronnie and
you know Ronnie and James did a really
good job oh really i mean i really have
to take my hat off to them they kind of
kept things it's not easy when you've
got a group of actors and the scenes are
involving a group of actors not you know
you're one or two heads do you know what
i mean so you know but it's a great car
something Sheridan's fab and a Cannes
fat on you know their hates a light
running really annoying Gus yeah just oh
darling it was so marvelous on sent it
was amazing but it was kind of pretty
cool tell me about the locations for
filming both tower block and the Kathryn
Bigelow movie because obviously they're
gonna be very very different although
different well one was in Jordan and the
other one was in East London what was
the experience like in Jordan pretty
intense i flew in and out literally was
only there for a week so in and out did
my stuff and moved again with this it
was spread over a few weeks couple of
days couple of days in couple of days I
mean what was great is he gave me the
opportunity to work with Cain it cuz me
and play kind of double act and you know
I bizarrely enough he'd just been in top
boy who are very different on my knee
under Maj had directed and Yun had been
telling me how brilliant Cain was
because they and really liked someone
actors but and it was true okay was
really natural and really easy to work
with and of course I find out he's his
huge grime artist I didn't know man I'm
like you okay and I don't know I'm sorry
what's your kind of me is it then I love
I do like prime which is I'm not of an
age where I kind of listen to music in
that kind of way it sounds so old have I
been slippers man look what I've got a
bit of slippers I'm working on the pipe
you